los browns boys o chicos orgullosos son
quizás los más nombrados fundado en 2016
el grupo ha liderado varias marchas
armadas con sus prendas amarillas y
negras actúan junto a los supremacistas
blancos y son leales atom cambio el
republicano no ha rechazado sus acciones
violentas
usted chicos orgullosos retrocedan y
esperen al auto igual pero te diré
alguien tiene que hacer algo con antifaz
de izquierda porque este no es un
problema de derecha este es un problema
de izquierdas la vio el llamado partido
tradicionalista de los trabajadores es
un grupo de neonazis que también
protagoniza enfrentamientos armados
contra los anti fascistas como ocurrió
en charlottesville virginia con una
protesta supremacista en la que murieron
tres personas y otras 34 resultaron
heridas
otra corriente que ha ganado
protagonismo son los conspiracionistas
de que el movimiento fundado en 2017
cree que trump lucha contra un estado
profundo liderado por pedófilos
satánicos que secuestran niños y
cultivan su sangre creen que trump envía
mensajes codificados con los vestidos
verdes de melania o con corbatas rosadas
los nuevo confederados quieren de vuelta
el nacionalismo y defienden los símbolos
de los estados donde predominaba la
esclavitud
creo que tenemos una república que
salvaría una constitución que defender a
favor
la bandera de amarilla con la serpiente
de cascabel representa a gadsden flex un
movimiento anti gobierno que defiende a
trump al igual que flipper centers
conocido por reclutar a militares
aunque el fbi considera muchos de estos
grupos como una potencial amenaza de
terrorismo doméstico que tienen vínculos
activos con policías durante el gobierno
de trump no se priorizaron las
investigaciones en su contra y ahora
muchos están congregados en el
movimiento que cree sin fundamentos que
a trump le robaron las elecciones